I couldn't go to the you makes a snail
sweater since I started getting big lead
by like jiff pom no you know jiff palm
uh uh is it an animal yeah it's a little
fuzzy I'm really Pomeranian dog hmm
who's just a star at these things and
what's it what's gifs skillset I mean
Jill jiff actually has some skills
really you know I would like as much as
I would like to sit here and you can
like walk on his hand
that's cool yeah dude I know a [__]
uh yeah I know a couple of dogs that
have [__] that little thing ya know
dude you could probably hire a wolf to
[__] sneak in there and eat little
jiff brother who died anything at first
dude I know a guy could probably [__] a
snack on that little bastard how big is
it he's like this big I mean don't get
me wrong he's he's super cute he's a
cute little fuzzy dog but you know I was
on a red carpet one time and the guy
said they said hey that guy's gonna
interview go over there and I walk over
to him and I'm like just standing there
and the guys like not really like
looking at me he's like looking like
passed me and I'm like standing there
like okay they told me to like come get
interviewed by this guy anything hey man
so sorry we're actually gonna do jiff
right now so wow I'm like so yeah I
didn't ask for this yeah want me to come
over here and now I'm getting big-league
by a little ball that was rough man that
was a tough well the good thing is
Jeff's only gonna live probably most
eight more six more years and you know
to be honest but dude yeah that's got to
be baffling now do you do is there a
little bit of ego in that where you're
like [__] this is [__] I mean you
never want to feel like that correct
like I don't like those things anyways
and it's like I don't like want to get
caught up and all that but when someone
tells you go over there get rid of you
and you're like I'm gonna go with the
flow and then you state your get over
there and then the guys like ooh
actually man as if I asked to get
anything right no I hate that yeah ask
to be put in a position where like I'm
getting flexed on by a little Pomeranian
yeah under view a dog anyways what do
they do this then oh wow he has that
ball and they're showing a picture right
now jiff got some football and that's
Jeff all things dog blog yeah see the
picture above seems walking on his hands
it's not this isn't one of those Chinese
dogs that they give it the pills and its
tongue hangs out of his mouth is it you
say give those things pills yeah there's
a big bunch of stuff now but we looked
at up Chinese dopin cute animals or
something I don't know what you would
but yeah they're giving him pills that's
why you know they're all just tongue out
of there I was just the type of dog you
just like was a slob just been drinking
all day
[Laughter]
no but the Chinese have been doing a lot
of that thing and I also get you know
who knows it but this what do you see in
it I haven't gotten anything about the
controversy but here's a marketing type
did Manny the dog ever weird sorry how I
know that yeah I don't wanna know you
know Manny the dog I mean now that I'm
looking at him they definitely look like
they could be drugged oh do you see a
Bichon on a couple of quaaludes bro no
the game has changed for these animals
it's not the same as it used to be when
you have around they're born into this
family nice for ya
well thanks for watching that video
right there that was a beautiful little
segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe subscribe